les grands crus n'intéresse pas que les
connaisseurs mais aussi les voleurs le
mâconnais et ses environs ont été la
cible de plusieurs cambriolages ces
derniers temps première victime
l'établissement gauthier à cuisery fin
décembre tous les meilleurs millésimes
de ce caviste ont été dérobés en une
nuit
un préjudice estimé à cent mille euros
mais surtout des années de travail
évanoui dans la nature tiens un
préjudice qui est énorme puisque donc
nos stocks comté constitué depuis de
très nombreuses années on achète les
vins beaucoup en souscription donc ce
qui nous permet de d'avoir des
millésimes d'avoir des prix compétitifs
et c est tout le stock de tous ces
grands vins ça tous été volés dans la
nuit du 29 au 30 dans l'ain c'est la
cave de georges blanc qui a subi une
tentative de cambriolage
le chef étoilé possède 140 mille
bouteilles dont certaines valent
plusieurs milliers d'euros
un trésor qui a donné des ailes à
l'audacieux voleurs et met directement
ici là au coeur de cette cave où il y
avait bien sûr des flagrants incroyable
magnum de romanée-conti notamment
qu'elle aurait normalement pas dû
rentrer ici là ce que l épique mais je
pense qu'on va fermer complètement la
tentative a échoué mais dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi c'est une autre table
étoilée qui a été victime d'un vol
la cave de la meule l'oise à chagny a
été visité et plusieurs grands crus ont
été subtilisés
la gendarmerie enquête sur ces affaires
et propose également des conseils de
sécurité et l'agent l'embrouillé très
fortement mobilisés engagés pour lutter
contre ces cambriolages à la fois en
occupant le terrain de manière
préventive et dissuasive nous avons
d'ailleurs récemment engagé
l'hélicoptère de dijon pour appuyer les
gendarmes qui conduisait une manoeuvre
de contrôle de zone au sol nous sommes
également engagés dans des enquêtes
judiciaires nombreuses qui vont aboutir
je l'espère j'invite les commerçants les
chefs d'entreprise a sollicité la
gendarmerie nous avons des spécialistes
et référent sûreté qui gracieusement
peuvent mettre leurs compétences au
profit des chefs des chefs d'entreprise
ou des commerçants pour faire un
diagnostic de sécurité qui permet
ensuite de prendre les mesures adéquates
difficile de dire pour l'instant si tous
ces vols ont été réalisés par les mêmes
auteurs seule certitude ces cambrioleurs
font preuve de
coût de das